race' my strength oh did not walk this
road to Babi Yar for many decades but
after the monument for the murdered
children was erected the dance
instructor has come here repeatedly with
her pupils my words are always this
monument could have been for me you in
your blue but I survived
in the early autumn of 1941 Nazi
Germany's army the vert mocked captured
Kiev
soon after bombs exploded in the center
of the city killing German soldiers in
order to fight the fires and secure the
strategic roads the SS and German and
Ukrainian police ordered all the city's
Jews to assemble on September 29th and
to bring only the essentials with them
but kilometer long line of people was
marched off including three-year-old
ricin and her family
I saw the grown-ups legs
I called them white grandpas they only
had underwear on long johns and
undershirts stained with blood all
around with the Germans and their local
helpers the people on the sidelines were
screaming they're taking these people to
be shot don't protest oh well shoot us
to each other there is no film
documentation of the mass executions but
a German soldier took a few photos
showing the waiting Jews and the
clothing of the victims it was decades
after the atrocity before the Soviet
Union raised a monument to the victims
in Babi Yar and it's monumental indeed
raised the two took a long time before
she chose to face the past my
grandmother never talked about it she
was silent for fear of traumatizing me
she didn't say what happened to hear
them all I saw was no no and that's why
I didn't start dealing with it until 50
years later
she started thinking about the massacre
long after she had a family and headed a
dance school and she visited the
memorial site
then race a road choreography to Babi
Yar it helped her overcome her trauma
but each performance is still a
tightrope walk it's an ambivalent
feeling on the one hand as a
professional I make sure my pupils do
everything right but if they do
everything right then I'm overcome with
emotion today Babi Yar ravine is
overgrown with vegetation the place
where almost thirty four thousand people
were shot dead in just two days is
hardly recognizable Raisa escaped the
murders because her Ukrainian
grandmother pulled her out of the line
of the doomed
we just ran away to the cemetery over
there my grandma ran until she could run
no more then she fell to the ground we
huddled between the gravestones all
night race has survived by hiding in
cellars until the Nazis were defeated
many years ago she encountered a German
tour guide in another memorial site in
Poland I looked at him and I could see
that he had taken the whole burden of
the German nations guilt upon himself
you understand and that's when I
reconciled with Germany before that of
course I was embittered
today Rice's husband is buried in the
cemetery where she escaped the murderers
and one day the place where she was
rescued will be her final resting place